من عمان ينضم الينا زوجان لاكثر من 35
عاما نهى الجبيري والسيد جاد الرب اهلا
بكما نهى
وسيد جاد يسعد صباحكم معنا تسمعني
يسعد صباحك يسعد صباحكم يعني باعتقادكم
انتم الاثنين بدنا نسمع تجربتكم يعني شو
كلمه السر السعاده الزوجيه للناس اللي
بتشوفنا اليوم كلمه السر
انا بالنسبه لي كلمه السر الصبر
والتفاهم
والمحبه والحياه السعيده
والصبر طبعا قبل اي شيء ولازم يعني الواحد
كمان ان يسمع الكلام يفهم الحياه الي قدام
منه كيف عشان تقدر تستمري في حياتك
لاكثر من 35 سنه
وغيره المواد
بالثقه في التعامل والامان يعني
حبك بالكلمات
ونزول في العلاقه يعني الحياه ما بتكون
كامله ميه بالميه من حيث السعاده الزوجيه
لكن كيف بنقدر احنا باقل الخسائر بالمنام
ننجح هاي العلاقه نخليها تدوم سنين وعقود
اوكي
انك انت تكوني متفاهمه في الحياه وبتفهمها
تكون في الصبر ويكون الواحد خلوق ويقدر
يتفاهم في الحياه ويقدر انه يسعد اللي
قدام منه عشان هو كمان يكون سعيد ويكون
صبور
والحياه الزوجيه اما بكون فيها اولاد كمان
بتكون صبرها اكثر وحلوها اكثر
وبتقدري انت تمارسي حياتك تكون عاديه يعني
كمان تكون مطيعه الزوجه المطيعه اللي بتحب
زوجها وبتحب بيتها واولادها اكيد ان هي
بتحب كل شيء في الحياه
بالعكس انت اللي بتجيب الوضع المادي وانت
اللي بتقدري تعيشي حالك وتقدري تصبري في
الحياه ومن هون بتجيء الحياه السعيده
مدارس
فانت بتكوني الصبوره في الحياه وبكون
مبسوطه وسعيده وهذا اهم شيء